all right Rebel
Rebel uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally uh originally I was
born in Connecticut
but I was raised all over
tell me about your family uh my mom uh
comes from a family that's real big uh
and
it was like there was a bunch of kids
and you know it's like freaking my
grandpa was a mute
he couldn't talk right
but uh he was a great big old boy but in
close to seven foot tall red meatball
burger and you just [__]
it was depression the depression so
[__]
he
raised a bunch of kids to [__] have
you know to work the field
was your dad in the picture no my dad
[__] was raising an orphanage
and cooking he just I don't know how him
and my mom got together for cooking
they had they ended up having [__]
four kids
and
it was a there was Michael
Diane
Stanley and David that was our family
you know it was like give her all the
keys to the family and
just it was a strange life because we
traveled so much
and like you travel through the South
yeah we went down south because my uncle
[__] my mom and my dad got drinking
one night and
my dad didn't like where he was working
for a painting company
and cooking my uncle too much
coming to Nashville with us
and my Jackson was coming to Nashville
there's a lot of opportunity for work
and housing and [__]
in uh Nashville so we went to [__]
Nashville
and
I was only a white boy
in my in my great great class they
cooking it was it was blacks and one two
white boys
that was it
and they [__] I asked my sister what
are we doing it's like go to school to
learn
and I [__] around and chased the girls
go to school to learn
so I I learned a little bit
later on in life I forget I've had a
bunch of different jobs I'm a carpenter
a Mason a landscaper
but the best job I think I ever had or
that I enjoyed anyways were working for
California convertibles and seeing me
valid what were you doing uh I just
whatever the boss told me to do I would
drill holes
to make [__] a kit to convertibilize
a jaguar
make it convertible yeah I see
and it would it would come up in
sections in three three different
sections the roof was would raise up
all motorized
and we just
slowly raise up and you latch it at the
two corners
so that when you were driving it
wouldn't [__] blow open
it was kind of a strange [__] for it
being as much as you pay for that kind
of car you think it would be you know
motorized
he just [__] it was a trip so you're
living on the streets now here today
you're down in Skid Row how long you've
been on the streets uh I've been on
streets off and on since I was like
[__] 14.
and the only thing you could do
I really felt accomplished in doing was
getting my GED
because freaking going I I didn't get
along with kids because I was small
everybody wanted to pick on me
[__] I've got a bad temper people get to
[__] with me I look for [__] to whack
them with
and my girlfriend is Happy why the [__]
you always gotta hate people with you
because I'm little and people [__] with
me
I mean [__] with me I whack them with
[__]
how far'd you go in school
um I got a GE
I understand that because I went to I I
went to 11th grade
but it was just [__]
like I said I didn't get along with
other kids and chicks so freaking there
was always drama and problems
and it didn't
I quit school
14 times yeah and
I went [__] one day [__] one of my
girlfriends told me hey
you think you could pass the test
what what test what are you talking
about she said the GE I said I don't
know
she's like well I'll help you I'll study
with you and I'll help you so [__]
sure enough she started with me and I
the day that we took the test
I handed YouTube and you told me man
it'll be about a week
before you hear anything don't trip
you smoke weed yeah it's like I got you
you gave me an ounce of bird I told him
what's this going to cost me he said it
ain't gonna cost you on man because you
help me I'm helping you don't trip
all right
[__] I teach it with him all afternoon
later on in that ass man you have kids
huh do you have kids I've got three
where are they
I don't know
I just cooking because I work Carnival
and [__] and I traveled I never knew
where the [__] we were going the next
day oh you worked at carnivals [__] yeah
bust your ass working for the carnival
because everything's heavy it's pig iron
you know it's like [__] everything's
real heavy and your work you know you've
worked that morning doing the shows
[__] with people and talking to your
girls
but in the evening it's actually where
you work
you know you've been here all [__]
day [__] with people you know trying
to do what you're supposed to do
but they did not
that's when infected it's that's hard
hard because [__] you've been working
and [__] with people all day already
so you're already tired and you got to
work all [__] night to move the show
how long were you working as a Kearney
um about five years
I wouldn't recommend it to anybody it's
dangerous it's hard ass work
and the people that you're [__]
trying to entertain
90 percent of them ain't worth the [__]
because they ain't trying to help you
you just because you just there
alcohol and drugs have been part of your
life
All of Me
which one started first
pardon which started first alcohol
yeah
the alcohol because my my dad mom drank
[__] so it was always around
and even if the kid cooking
you would sneak drinks when you know
when Mom and Dad would catching a buzz
they weren't paying attention enough
that you couldn't see some of their [__]
[__] would go hide in the bathroom
and drink
what kind of drug are you
I'm a mean drunk
even though I'm little I mean
I put you people just talking [__] I'll
whack me with something
and my girlfriend asked me why'd you
always like that or you always got to
hit people with [__] because I'm little
you end up in jail sometimes pardon you
end up in jail sometimes a lot of times
it's just looking
I've been to numerous County jails
but I've been in the FED prison I've
been a regular prison I did five years
in the figs
were important 86 pounds of marijuana
and [__] my dad asked me how the [__]
you come up with all that but I said it
wasn't my bud
I was just a driver
and we drove from [__]
uh America
and go all the way to [__] Mexico
City
[__] two times I'm [__] months
and I asked you dude that was running
[__] how the [__] if you're only going
two times a month how the [__] are you
making money
you told me
we don't work it ain't us we work for
somebody I'm like who you work for he
said don't worry about it I got you
all right
sure enough he had me
and picking
I [__] that up because
I like the drugs [__]
you know you can't do dope
and expect to be normal
and that's kind of dope I do and it's
not freaking doing big shots of petty
and smoking and [__]
you're either [__] an [__]
or you want to go get something to stick
your dick in you know so it's like
[__] life life was hard man
the drugs do you typically play around
with
um we in [__] mess
and everybody asked me why why meth It's
like because as a kid I was a real one
child
I'm real hyper I always got locks energy
and [__] they told me we got
something for you and they put me on a
really one
Ritalin is just a [__] Doctor's way
of saying
that picture we're gonna put you on uh
meth but it ain't meth it's Ritalin
but it's too [__] Ginger Man and
freaking life is just a strange
it was real strange for a long time man
have you been in love before
not real love it's always been loved it
[__] has always been a lie for for
some strange reason
God has given me what I'm supposed to
have yet and I said that one night and
one of the girls I was around asking
what the [__] is it that you're supposed
to have what you're supposed to have and
what you get isn't always the same [__]
you know the way my life is being
[__]
I got more bad than I got was good
uh it's like people something why you
like yours because [__]
if that [__] always happens to you what
the [__] do you expect out of life but
bad [__] you know what I mean it's like
so we drinking do drugs so that we can
[__] forget it for a minute
in the ass
every time
it was just [__] life's been strange
what's your biggest regret
not [__]
during that [__] how to praise God
right
because that's what we're here for if we
really [__] look at what we're here
for it was to honor God
it's just it don't turn out that way
because [__]
people want to do what they want to do
you know they just show and it's usually
the wrong [__]
everybody want to do the wrong thing
instead of doing the right thing
um
when I was a kid in Arkansas I hung out
in a baking
parking lot and one of my homeboys asked
me why I said because nobody [__] with
me here I can shoot hoops and the people
like
what people watching
see
and she came out of her [__] dog
house I thought be good
she's like why'd you tell her that I
said because if I don't tell her to be
good and you get too closer she might
bite your ass so
be careful
two days later [__] say he grabbed
his ass by the [__] head
[__]
nasty little [__] that [__] dog was
strange man nasty little [__]
most dogs groomed herself
so you can give a [__]
she'd be all nasty and dirty and [__]
and
she can get [__]
well walk over the world bed wasn't lay
down and go to [__] sleep
steal from fire
I bet she gabs your ass
sure enough she [__] latched onto his
coat
I said coaching
I said she ain't beat you yet I don't
think she's gonna invite you
she just got a hold of you to [__]
show you that you [__] up
how old are you Rebel
I'm 57. oh I just turned 57 January
January 20th Martin Luther King Day
what do you uh
what do you fear most what do you worry
about now
what what are you afraid of at this
point of your life
um
what I'm afraid of is uh [__]
not cooking do you know the [__]
take care of myself man in fact I'll get
old
you know I'm literally suicide [__]
people got to [__] with me and do stupid
[__] and when I get all pissed off and
want to hit them
[__] well [__] why'd you do that [__]
man
you think I'm not gonna hate you with
something
oh why you gotta hit me with something
cause I'm little
if you [__] with me I'm a whack you with
something so you don't can't so you
can't hit me again you know it's like
[__] life is strange where the green
apple is
I got hit on that little walkway the
ramp way
with a [__] something
talking
I got hit three times that I remember
and especially
I moved over a little bit with that
walkways between the green apples here
and there's a [__] some kind of
program house or something here across
the street corner
and [__] that's that's where I got
hit
and I remember
sitting on my on my knees
and
all the blacks in the neighborhood
were howling at drive work
[__] you
that's what I said I'm sitting here
[__] bleeding [__] [__] me man
as I ever why'd you tell them [__]
because I was being and I didn't know
who the [__] hit me
you know it's like [__]
I sit there in a bed for a while man
and of all people
and always you guess who come to ask if
I needed help
a big old tea Batgirl
she told me you all right wood
how I [__] you man she's like no man
I'm trying to help him are you all right
I'm sitting here bleeding lady yeah let
me go get some stuff to help you man and
she sure enough she came back with
bandages and banished up my [__] in
the head
and told me come on come on she's like
come on I'm gonna bring you to the
corner I'm gonna put your ass in the car
I'm gonna take you to hospital
and what the [__] did you just do all
that for
you know she's helped
all right
just Doctor Strange sometimes
and these [__] cutting the
situation off
where do you stay at night do you have a
tent or anything like that uh just
wherever
I usually try to go [__]
where there ain't nobody
that way acting [__] lay down and go
to sleep and not be [__] with
just don't want to work out like that
living on the streets is rough yeah
Rebel what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
excuse me what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
to praise God
because
if we don't praise him
he might have looked our ass
oh it's like
and one of the people I was keeping with
told me what the [__] you mean by that I
said well if we don't show God honor and
praise
we honor them
by worship
and the only way that I can worship God
it seems
is with music
and people ask them what the [__]
anybody I said I played guitar and I
sing I make money doing it so I'm doing
something right
all right Rebel thank you so much for
sharing your story
wish you lots of luck out here I'm sure
stay safe